whoa look at all this
we have land hey
what's up guys so it's been a minute
since we have shown you
what's going on around the house some
things have changed
other things have stayed the same most
of the things have stayed the same but
most of the things have changed
how beautiful you are oh you're so sweet
especially right now since i have no
makeup
that's so nice you're so sweet i mean
you look great because you just got a
haircut
oh so that's changed yeah that's changed
i've uh
glowed up oh
for starters let's talk about this
we got a new rug for the entrance
i really like the design it's actually
like a navy blue i don't know if you
guys could tell but
from far away it looks dark it looks
darker there's maya
saying hi oh she literally said hi when
i said hi how cute
oh you're so cute i love you so much
maya okay moving on
cats have more places to climb now
true but i was going to mention ignore
the fact that these pillows are here
you guys already know why they're there
and if you don't i'll tell you right now
it's because our cat likes to poop on
the couch and not this beautiful
nice tamed cat it's the other one that
guy
anyway oh yeah and then also we got what
are these thingies called
defense like acupressure system 2.5
yeah because we're putting just pillows
here you know he just likes pooping in
this corner
which is very infuriating because this
is the corner that
i like to relax and so it feels like a
personal attack
that's why that's here but i wanted to
point out this
the rug we got a new rug ties the room
together
yeah and then also i brought down the
stool that i was keeping
in our closet and i was like wait it
actually matches the couch perfectly
so then i brought that one down and i
don't know if you guys remember but it's
the one that has
the table if you flip it it's pretty
cool i like this thing a lot
and i like it so much that i bought
another one
and it actually works out really well
because when i'm hanging out on the
couch right here i'm just chilling
and then i'll bring that thingy closer
and then it's a foot rest
yeah just trying to make the most out of
this space trying to fill in the space
you should have a tea party over here
this is like such a nice like
zen spot with the rug now yeah
like some tea over here bohemian mint
tea it's a mint tea yeah
moroccan style mint tea i mean we did
buy this set
in morocco and a mini tagine we should
make them in tajin
yeah so that's different
another thing that's different i just
felt like our our
floors needed to be judged up
so that's why i got rugs oops wrong
light i got this one
this one just came in today and it's
really cute i like it a lot i love the
colors
totally matches the vibe up here you
know with the the blue
and the the greens and all that stuff
and then this one arrived yesterday
excuse
the unmade bed i we just took a nap so i
got this
gigantic rug and the plan is to somehow
put it under the bed who knows how we're
gonna do that i'll lift it up with one
finger
right man this is a pain in the butt i
ended up doing this all by myself
when it came in it was folded up in like
a tiny little square just so they could
package it better
this is a 9x12 rug it's gigantic
and like i opened it up i laid it across
the bed and i'm just like trying to see
what it looks like
it's a really pretty rug i'll show you
guys once we end up eventually putting
it under the bed where it's supposed to
be and i know you guys must be wondering
why the heck is she buying
rugs to put on top of a carpet that
seems weird
and actually no it's very smart because
i'm trying to preserve
our carpets that we bought and we paid
for with some rocks
you know in the high traffic area rugs
are good and plus it just
it ties the room together right yeah
ties the room together
just gives more vibrance and more design
and more
like a museum you just walk through your
own house it's like that's interesting
you stare
for like a good 20 minutes you stare at
our rugs for 20 minutes
yeah if it's a work of art you know you
get to process
what you're looking at the visual
stimulation it makes it feel more homey
too like
because it feels like we we did that you
know because like
this carpet was one out of 20
designs that you get to choose you know
and everything was way more than 20
designs there's a lot of designs but
like i'm just saying like a lot of other
people could have this
with in our neighborhood or whatever too
so it's like this is our
chance to like be different be different
it's like as if you
went to school or required to wear
uniforms like school uniforms
people use accessories to
show their personality and that's kind
of what we're doing with all these rugs
and just interior design okay but on to
the most exciting thing ever
the reason why you clicked on this video
so this is the current state of our
backyard
obviously it is not 100 completed
because we had to take a little hiatus
in order for us to order some things
well now we're just missing one more
thing
yeah which is like a stainless steel
door for us to use here to open
that fridge right there yeah that fridge
is going
in that corner and then these two white
boxes are stainless steel drawers
that will be going in these two holes
here and then we got the
the grill already all set up we're just
missing the countertops
and matching the stucco to our house
the house color and that's pretty much
it so right now
you guys are gonna be seeing some b-roll
footage of the process
of the backyard so let's go through it
in the beginning they first
like smashed up all the cement around
here like
messed up the dirt for some reason
whatever foundation things
and then they ended up pouring the
cement i think first here right
yes first yeah first on this area
where we're having our fake deck
wow look at that
there's cement back there you can work
our fingers or
hands or something well it's going to be
covered with fake wood
so we're not going to be able to see it
you can do down here though it dries so
fast so we can't even
we can ask him but hey can we put our
fingerprints all right so today
day three they got to finish
pouring the cement over here very nice
very nice
and got a little step going on a little
mini step over here this cement is gonna
get
the tile treatment this stuff
looks like wood but it's actually
ceramic just waiting for this to dry
and then the counter space
and what's cool is we already got this
guy
man traeger smoker and it's just parked
in here for now
and eventually we're gonna move it
outside where it belongs
it was so cool once i realized what
material we were using because i thought
we were going to be using the laminate
that we have inside the house
but it turns out it's ceramic tile that
is made to look like wood which is such
a beautiful workaround
because initially we wanted to have a
deck with like real wood and stuff and
then i remember like his parents were
mentioning how
you don't want to have a deck you're
going to have rats living under there
it's going to be gross
the wood heats up and it just makes like
everything really hot and when you walk
over it's like
yeah like creaks and stuff rick he ended
up recommending
to just pour cement and then on top of
it like the face of it
use these ceramic wood tiles and as he
was working through it
we were just like what that's so crazy
because you can actually like you'll
feel like
this is this is ceramic it's not wood
after they pour the cement up here then
they pour the cement down there
and then they moved on to scoring the
cement because if you guys remember
we talked about how i'm going to be
painting on top of the cement with
stencils it's going to look
like a really nice pattern i still
haven't determined which colors i'm
going to be using but i do have the
stencils already and that's the reason
why they scored it so
it looks like 12 by 12 tiles after that
they started building the actual
countertop and
measuring out where the girl is going to
be going
this is so nice at that
outside countertops are gonna be better
than our inside countertops
yeah i like this pattern a lot more i
love this pattern
i like this a lot better it looks more
grand the fact that they're bigger veins
because the one that we have inside the
house yeah it's like little baby veins
the baby things this is the artery yeah
that's true
your parking spot has been taken over
it's a construction site now
you know the feelings you get when the
house is being built and it's like this
is gonna be this is
mine look it's gonna be mine and i'm
gonna be able to enjoy this
now i'm getting that feeling all over
again except this time it's really
customizable by us
true like it's like we actually got to
design it you designed it yeah
yeah this is your mastermind over here
well hold on we can say that once it's
done
because i'm like we're still like in the
middle of it the floor is like i came
out here and it's always like dust in
your hands it's all grimy
yeah now i'm like i can kind of envision
the way it's going to feel
when you stand out here once it's all
like you see now you got the lines
carved out
there so you can kind of picture what
the tiles will look like now
and then like there's a shape of like
the countertop
i'm happy yeah
[Music]
this is done today beautiful
wood faux wood tiles and then finally
measuring the traeger
we're gonna see if we can fit it in this
little crevice here
that has a nice little home rather than
being up against the wall
[Music]
all right this is after day six
six move this over here
and we got this going on now building
the counter space
and it looks like in here this is where
that grille
is going to be here we have an outlet
here
so then once they started building the
countertops along the wall of the house
that's when we realized like oh my gosh
there's gonna be
so much space inside of the countertops
that are it's just gonna be dead space
and i don't know why i never done it
yeah we didn't think about it
didn't you put storage area we only
thought about the fridge
that's the only thing what we considered
like to use it for so we're like oh yeah
we should have a fridge
but we completely forgot and didn't
didn't even think about
the rest of the countertop and so that's
when we had asked rick
we're like oh so sorry this is literally
in the middle of the project
but can we add some sort of storage like
maybe drawers or like cabinets or
something or like shelving or something
and so rick was like oh yeah he was
super cool really flexible with us and
was like yeah don't worry just order the
stuff
we'll install it we'll make room for it
as we're building out the countertops
that's exactly what happened and that is
the reason why
they completely stopped working because
we were waiting for all the things to
come in
from ordering
so that's kind of been the process of
our backyard
it's been pretty great because we we are
so impatient we could not wait
for them to be completely done so we
started building out
our outdoor furniture as you can see
[Music]
all right so we spent all day building
this couch is outdoor couch and uh we
just wanted to see
how well this umbrella that we built
earlier
is gonna fit in that corner
all right so the moment a truth is a
little bit of a disappointment so we got
this guy in there like obviously we said
we wanted to see if it would fit
and uh it takes that much space to do
that
and now our couch looks like that but
then it's just
i don't know don't know what to do with
this big old gap now but i like the
couch though this is nice very pretty
look at the table finish the table first
and we'll worry about that
later
and that was so silly because that day
we had other things to do like more
important things to do and accomplish
you're probably making this video that
you're watching right now
yeah and so there were just other things
that we should have been prioritizing
but
that day we were just like oh my god we
all the things came in like finally all
the boxes for the furniture came in and
we're like let's just build it and see
what it looks like because we're just so
excited and we wanted to see what it
would look like all together worth it
totally worth it it's worth it
come over here well let me turn on the
light because this umbrella
has little like i mean it's not very
bright but
it's ambient you know i got this little
chime
with the hummingbird in the middle yeah
so
we've been hanging out here for the last
few days since we built this stuff out
and just enjoying it like i think we've
had what two or three breakfasts
breakfast well we haven't had breakfast
together yet yeah we had breakfast
because i've been having a really busy
morning so
you wake up earlier than me too the
reason why i got this set though
it was really difficult to find because
i was trying to find
a lounge set that can also be used as
dining and i didn't want dining chairs
so i wanted like an actual l couch and
luckily somehow
this was i think there were maybe two
other contenders but
like in total just three sets that i was
looking at in order to fit in this space
and i found this one and had this table
in case you guys are wondering what kind
of table says it's called a chow
table like a chao like height tau height
or something
you know but yeah yeah it means child
like to eat but it's also like casual
dining i think they referred to it i
don't know if you guys are curious you
want to go look for outdoor furniture
that's
what i came across and i found this set
absolutely happy with it
love it but the thing is because of the
way that this
entire foundation turned out okay so
it does slope so they had to slope it
down
in order to meet the gate over there
they actually chopped the gate too
they did a really clean job and that
point that's the reason why
this this entire foundation this
leveling is
slow so on this side is a lot lower than
if you sit on that side
and for that reason i recently purchased
some bed risers so we're going to be
putting risers underneath this furniture
to like level it up
because even this table i don't know if
you guys could tell but it slopes down a
little bit
yeah because so i got the citronella
candle to like
deter the mosquitoes and stuff and as
the
the wax melts you could see like on this
side of the candle it's like
way more pulled up than on this side
because of how slanted you could even
i don't know if you could tell from the
water but yeah it's okay it was
um it was a necessary thing to do
in order for everything to work out
because of the fact that we had asked
specifically to have this fake deck side
to be more elevated
than down there and that's the reason
why they were making us happy by
elevating it but it's like oh no wait
we gotta slant it down to make the gate
fit
but now we can see just slightly more of
that mountain back there
and that's mainly the reason why we
wanted this to be higher we like our
mountain
the view the view let's talk about those
bushes my dad called me like as soon as
i sent him some pictures he was like
your ac unit
you cannot be covering it with bushes
because if there's anything he's ever
learned about
ac units through being a homeowner is
that ac units will
die and break down very fast if you uh
don't allow a whole lot of room on the
sides for the ac unit to breathe and
pull in the air for the unit to actually
work and function so
what we've done here with you know the
bushes and covering it up
is the opposite of ideal we are
now trying to figure out a way to cover
up the ac unit without suffocating it
yeah by that we mean removing the plants
and
finding like a bamboo thingy majiggy
yeah so
initially we wanted to cover the ac unit
the same way that the model home covers
it and
they use artificial hedges uh i was
looking into those
they're really expensive i feel like if
we are gonna go that route we have to go
in person and pick out
all these artificial plants and like
measure it up and see like okay
is this gonna actually work and cover it
another option
is getting like some rolled up bamboo
like fencing and just put bamboo around
it
and it's covered out of sight so i don't
know what we're gonna end up
going with yet but in the meantime
they're still there
eventually we're gonna pull them out of
the ground put them in pots
put them along this wall here and just
use them
for that purpose in the meantime um i
forgot to mention but you guys see that
the rocking chair set over there
that is meant for the front of the house
which we'll check out in a bit
actually we don't have to you guys can
see it from the b-roll it's just cement
it's scored cement right now and
eventually that's gonna be painted
with the stencils that i'm trying to do
back here oh another thing that we're
planning on doing is having a fountain
along that brick wall over there so
eventually
hopefully there'll be a fountain there
so we have this this piece of furniture
in the front right now which is a bench
that it's like a storage bench
the idea is to move that bench back here
and have that bench
live along that wall and that's where
we're gonna keep our outdoor shoes
goal is to try to garden some stuff we
wanna try
our attempts at having a green thumb and
one of the i know for sure one of the
plants that we want to try to grow is
like a lemon tree have like a dwarf
lemon tree
even these plants is like a big
undertaking
i feel like it's like i don't know we've
tried planting in our previous place and
those plants pretty much died on us so
we uh we let them down so we don't want
to let these guys down so trying to
water them every day
yeah i mean those other plants too it
was kind of
hard to maintain because they lived in
the front
patio part of our house which we almost
never set foot in
and that's the reason why i was kind of
hard but ever since we've had the
furniture out here and we're just so
excited to have
an extension of our our living space
downstairs
by being out here we've been just more
aware of our surroundings out here so
i'm pretty sure if we had a lot of
plants we'd be
really into it we'll want to water it
actually hang out
here now like even though it's not
finished yet like every almost every
single day
we find at least an hour or two to come
out here and just lay out here and like
be on our phones or eat or just talk
like
the older couple now that's like just
sitting outside in their garden just
like
even though it's not 100 done like i'm
already
so happy with it so in love with it
already feeling like
okay we're getting our money's worth
yeah
doing your backyard it's a little pricey
it is
even though it's so small and like i
don't know like when i was a kid too
like i always thought like man like
construction
like how do they even do this stuff like
how do you even get any of this stuff
started and done and now we're actually
doing like it just feels like a really
like it's a grown-up thing like buying a
house is one thing but it was like
through
the realtor builder and yeah so it felt
hands-off but doing this
is like very hands-on that's true so
it's a very different experience than
building the house and
i don't know i'm really really happy
with the with the experience we're
having right now yeah me too
we'll see how this turns out when it's
100
100 done and see how that looks but yeah
we really set ourselves up
for a lot of work because once they come
back to finish everything
they're gonna do like a deep cleaning on
the floor and the walls and whatever
they got dirty
so that means we have to remove all of
this furniture that we built
so that's gonna be kind of fun yeah
it's gonna be kind of fun to just remove
all these things true
and then see how it works because it's
so funny right now we're using a bag
or two bags we're using two bags of the
rocks that they brought in so they can
fill
in that gap over there but we're using
them as weights right now for this
umbrella
because i had bought a different kind of
weight
and it totally didn't work so i have to
return that one and i purchased a new
one so we're waiting for that new one to
come
in it's just been really nice and shout
out to
modern landscaping llc rick and his son
and jaime they've been very very uh
just really awesome to work with and
they've been very open to our ideas and
tips like this is
tiff's design like the whole layout and
everything so
it's really cool that you know they've
worked with us and and
you know brought our ideas to life so if
you're interested in getting some
landscaping done
check the description down below for
their info and hit them up honestly
truly from the bottom of my heart i
truly
recommend this company because they are
just so attentive they're so
passionate too because passion is
important when you're doing things and
you can clearly tell that they have a
passion
for this stuff so i'm really glad that
we ended up going with them
because you guys saw us when we were
vlogging earlier when we're trying to
pick
landscapers it's just like oh my god
it's a process and also you get to see
different people's like professionalism
and how they approach
their craft with rick you could see like
he's really passionate about this
and obviously they've been doing a
fantastic job
it just feels so clean and professional
and
yeah i mean technically not sponsored
just check out the description if you
guys want to check them out alright see
you guys in the next video
bye peace
[Music]
me